uh when your big beautiful
butt cheeks are being held do you like
them parted or do you like your hips
held
to where the booty just flips back and
forth over the big
i like my hips to be held and i like to
like you know so i can still move back
and forth and
you know work it like torque it next
question oh professor x
to attain your epic what the is going on
what is this did he say professor x
professor charles xavier
that was good though oh professor x to
attain your epic ass can you describe
your exercise regime
and does it require you inserting things
into your butt
i don't exercise like ever unless i'm
like on the dock you know
but i do like to put things in my home
hmm
everything about it's like kicking it
now everything about this video is
amazing
yo shout out to the people who produce
this video hi uh do you feel that being
uh nominated for
uh most epic uh short changes your other
uh qualities look at though this is not
real this guy really went no no no hold
up is this the avn's
yeah oh okay it doesn't make it any more
understandable yeah yeah yeah it's the
abs what the [ __ ]
is that your short ass i mean qualities
this is good
no it doesn't because
we all have many amazing qualities
after the flat earth conference and the
furry con i decided to travel to las
vegas nevada for the avn expo the
largest
star meet and greet in the world come on
let's go inside
hey hi so what do you do for work i'm a
star
you have like on camera and stuff like
that all the time and i eat
on camera stick your tongue in really
deep
wiggle it around so you get a good taste
why
because it tastes really good like all
right you can jump on our patreon
because this
video is definitely getting demonetized
that is for sure for sure
if you want to uh support you can go on
the patreon or not that's fine that's
okay
but you can watch we'll also have a
podcast and everything and stuff back to
the shenanigans
what's your favorite movie um i like
titanic i would have been rose did you
cry during titanic
no i had sex with my friend during the
scene that they had
because we wanted to practice what they
were doing we were in elementary school
okay he's taking a picture of you you
want to say what's up tom brick come
here buddy ol pal
oh my god i'm getting tired okay i'll
hold
don't cross it anymore i'm over it okay
all right i thought that's maybe you
needed some help we're
in an interview right now you just got
caught on camera well i just
it was merely just a uh a brush it was
accidental
hey those are my friends from high
school come here i don't really have a
banana
come here the avian awards we love all
you guys yo all you
came out very pretty tonight yes i love
white cities
i suck at all these i suck on them all
day [ __ ] this is dope this is great
contact
i'm a content creator what i gotta say
okay i'll get y'all a little eight bars
little eight wars
bars i'm 25 years old this is my first
avn i'm
crazy about these chicks how old do you
say what 25.
i mean i know you rage like bread but
come on bro you know you're lying
25 you can add
another 60 on top of that this guy's
probably just like
that black kid who doesn't know how to
do math what's 9 plus 10
21 you're stupid what's 40 plus 30
25 that's what i think just happened
right there what is your
fantasy man meeting jenna jameson is he
here
i didn't see your doctor but you're
doing a great job and you're well
dressed thank you man have you seen her
what are you going to say
hello peace out hello and peace out
that's net it so we don't know i was cut
in the middle of that
so i'm gonna give him benefit of the
doubt i'm not if he said he's 25 and
he's got all the rings and he keeps
doing those hand gestures
there's no benefit of the doubt i think
he feels like if he just exit he'll be
you know like fake it till you make it
but there's no way you're making it back
in time bro
all right this is this isn't back to the
future give it up oh this is my dad
so you guys made it out as a father-son
bonding experience yep yep
you guys met riley reed together yep yep
what'd you guys say to her
i said i'm not worthy and i did the
wayneswell thing you're beautiful or
something like that
when you said that you wanted to bond
with your son i didn't think you guys
would bond over bondage
it seems a little bit odd that you all
went to the avian expose but hey
it seems like you have a great
relationship so good for you if that mom
like milf is super like it's hot
it's always hot i'm a sex therapist like
i'm a trained
therapist no you're not
no no you no you no you're not i'm
pretty sure he leads with that on tinder
would you like a session girl no you're
not close off
hey i'd like to get into your thoughts
and into you as well
you're not sarah right how are you doing
they got a bunch of beautiful women
if you want to get your uh fantasy
fulfilled
you go see the beautiful women that's
doing off my
i just love all women and i would love
to be involved
and have a relationship with any woman
that's willing to have a relationship
with me
there's a lot of sadness in this video
so i'm trying not to do too much
commentary
oh my dear women it's a perfect uh
coca-cola shape mommy you know big booty
you know how we do it
did he just throw a random brand insert
into his description of a perfect woman
hey you know my favorite thing is like
a woman with some chuck e cheese titties
and a girl with a top top hand knows
about it looking like
gap between her teeth but she got that
sean john in her face
everybody knows the coca-cola
[Music]
overwhelmed star struck
beyond words this is crazy this
is crazy thousands of dedicated fans
on the pilgrimage of a lifetime
but deep down i wondered was it all
worth it i educate my little coffee
betas
like my little cheer to understand that
there is a lot of respect that they
should have for black cake
yes absolutely oh i've seen like that
that is disgusting
[Laughter]
oh that is disgusting that is the
cringey [ __ ] i've seen
that is disgusting does she say
black kings yes because it's it's like
the within the cuck world
real talk real tough all right let's say
the hottest girl you've ever seen shows
up
and she got a white boot attached on a
sleesh like that and she says
i want you to [ __ ] me while this is
little i don't think you get it okay
they there's a sign for this and it's a
spade
because technically that's a slur for us
a spade but they use it
and these these the woman the dudes
sometimes they tattoo the spade on them
to show their allegiance to black kinks
yes
it's weird so you're saying you wouldn't
do it no
right i feel like for me i would have to
get to know them a little bit better
are you aware that you're a black king
uh no you're not aware that you're a
black king
uh you just made me aware i like how
quickly this guy caught on he went no
it's like
are you not aware he's like i like where
this is going uh yeah yeah you just made
me
aware and i'd like to know he's really
curious
see and that's part of the problem as
that black man especially in this
country you don't realize that you're a
black king and you are
thank you would you be at all
uncomfortable if my beta sexy cuck back
here
showed his respect and bent down on all
fours
and kiss the ground in front of your
feet or your feet themselves to show his
respect
you're obviously his superior so i don't
mind
do not mind thank you all right
[Music]
on all fours
now i want you to thank this black king
for letting you kneel before him
thank you sir now i understand what
stephen crowder was talking about
these are the people he was talking
about who said wanted him to kneel
keep in mind how that is right
asking white people all white people to
kneel and ask for forgiveness
i know when we said reparations we
didn't mean this
show respect and kiss the ground in
front of him because you respect the
ground he walks on don't you
yes goddess
thank you sir
that's good that was really good
you know that you're unworthy to beg for
his attention
you know that right yes goddess that the
only way that you should ever actually
be in front of a black king is on all
fours and that all black
men should know that they are kings yes
goddess
should all little white boys be trained
like you guess goddess
thank you so much thank you i appreciate
you imagine being that
white dude's family member and seeing
this video viral online
it would be very tough for me to look
that person the same way
if we had family dinner again
like if i was a white dude that was my
brother and we were having a family
dinner and i knew he was coming
i would bring my black friend that is i
would bring my black friend and be like
there's some parts of the floor you need
to clean up
i don't know this to me i get it it's
like but
wow that's past beyond sam i wonder if
dodgy cat's into this
how do you feel about the avian awards
i'm so i'm so sad i'm so mad
why because a darkness spirit he
controls this city america your
responsibility
to keep jesus to call keep jesus jesus
christ jesus christ jesus christ jesus
christ
no don't say like this okay i'ma get out
from a darkness life
i'ma get out from a darkness life you
make me
if you lost jesus christ you're going to
lose this country you're going to lose
this country america
wake up who are you in the name of jesus
i command you in the name of jesus
i command you in the name of jesus i
command you in the name of
jesus i command you in the name of jesus
i command in the name of jesus
i command you in the name of jesus i
command you in the name of jesus
pretty sure that guy's ethiopian he
definitely got her forehead
yeah i command you the name of a jesus i
just
it just so it's not like i just yeah i
don't know why
i decided to react to this video i don't
know why but it is what it is it's funny
because
uh when they do the gala they are
actually more dressed than people
at the the golden globes or some other
[ __ ] like that really
so it's yeah yeah these are pretty well
dressed
i would think i've ever going i'm
somebody who likes to watch prawn by
myself i don't share
videos with friends you know yeah so to
me go to this award like just be visible
would make me so uncomfortable
but it doesn't mean i'm necessarily
right or wrong just like my perception
on it but
it was a very funny video great job by
them if you guys can go check their
channel out um
but yeah it's just really really to
watch it's a world i'm not familiar with
already just
vegas it's just another world true can i
be honest with you though
most parts of america like that not
unless they like vegas but weird in
their own way
every american city that i've been to
i've been to quite a lot now
they are weird in their own different
way it's like a whole bunch of different
countries within one
fair like what you see in vegas yeah
it's completely
weird and then once you go to florida
you're gonna find some other weird real
too i've been
it's weird go to some parts of louisiana
[ __ ] it gets
weird something i appreciate about the
states it's uh
it's performative it's the best word i
could have for it yeah
but vegas i hate vegas it's not for me i
can understand that it's not for you
it's not even for a lot of the residents
the residents vegas is not for vegas
people vegas people just work for vegas
but
yeah yeah but it was that's a whole side
of the side story but
what did you guys think about the video
did you guys what the [ __ ] as well
are you guys kings we want to hear your
thoughts leave it in the comments below
you're not a king bro of course i'm a
king but not for that reason guys
for why